hi guys i'm raul from simply learn and
welcome to this video on how you can
install java on your windows operating
system in this video we'll be telling
you how you can install java and showing
you a very simple java program so let's
get started so first off let's go to
google and search for java here let's go
to this link and here you have a number
of different options first off we have
java se 13.01 which is the latest
release but we are going to go for java
sc8 which is the more commonly used one
which is used by most people around the
world so this is what we are going to
use so we select this and here we go
down a bit so to proceed we need to
accept the license agreement we've
accepted the license so now we can
download the software so we have two
options to choose from windows x64 or
x86 now if you have a windows 10
operating system it's highly likely that
you have a 64-bit operating system so
you can select this option now if you do
have a 32-bit operating system which is
probably like windows 7 you can select
the x86 option as well so now let's
click on this so you need to log in and
all that we've already finished and
we've have the download already so let's
get it
so now this dialog box will pop up now
we'll go to the next option here we'll
accept them the way they are
and now we'll wait for it to install
so now we need to select the destination
where you want the install to happen so
now this is installed in the program
files we select this if you want to
change it you can go to this option here
we don't want to change it we'll just go
from here to next and now we wait for
the installation to complete
so now the installation is complete now
we don't need to look at any other next
steps we'll just stop and go to close so
now we need to provide an environment
variable so what is that used for now if
you have files or applications that have
the java extension these help tell the
computer that we need to run it using
the java program so now let's create an
environment variable go to start go to
control panel and then we go to system
and then this pops up now before we
select the environment variables we need
to find the path where we install java
so i installed it in c drive here so
let's go there in c program files java
and here we have jdk and gre first we
select the jdk or the java development
kit we select it and go into bin where
all these files are present and where
the java file is present as well so now
we're going to copy this path now let's
go back to environment variables and
select path from here which is right
here now at the end of this we'll add a
semicolon and paste the path now
similarly we'll do the same thing for
jre so now we're going to do the same
thing with gre here which is the java
run environment so we'll go back select
gre go into bin and select the path from
here we add another semicolon and paste
the path we press ok and it's done press
ok here as well and now we're done now
to check whether java has been installed
in your system we need to go to the
command prompt here we'll type the term
java c which refers to the java compiler
now the output will show a number of
different options you can choose from
this is an indication that java has been
successfully installed in your system if
the installation wasn't successful the
statement like java c is not recognized
as an internal or external command
operable program or batch file will be
shown to you so now that we've set up an
environment of java in our computer
let's see how we can code java for this
we'll need to use an ide on which we can
run the java code we will be using
eclipse ide now there are several other
ides like intellij netbeans dr java and
so on first off we need to install
eclipse so let's go to google and search
for eclipse ide go here download select
this option and now we'll just click on
download so i've already downloaded the
exe file so let's just go there so then
this shows up so here you have a number
of different options eclipse can be used
for a number of different languages like
enterprise java c c plus plus javascript
php and so on so we need it for java
developers so we click this so this has
already determined where exactly the
java file is which you can see here it
shows the installation folder here and
now all we need to do is install we need
to accept the terms and conditions which
we'll just go through quickly except now
and now the installation has started we
remember accepted licenses accept
it this shows up you can select remember
accepted certificates select these
except selected and there you go the
installation is complete now let's
select launch now we need to set up the
eclipse ids workspace which you can
change if you want i'm just going to
keep it at this now we select launch and
here you go here is the eclipse ide now
let's have a look at how we can create a
very simple java program so first we'll
close the welcome tab and here we have
the package explorer now in case the
package explorer isn't shown for you
initially you can go to windows you can
go to show view and select on package
explorer so now let's have a look at how
we can create the program first we go to
file click on new and select java
project so here you need to input the
project's name i'm calling it proj 1.
press next
and here you see the src file or the
source file where all the source code is
located we press finish and it's done if
you click on this you can also see the
source file now we need to click on
source right click press new and create
a new class here you need to name your
class i'm calling it my class and finish
now within this we need to create the
main function which is public static
void
main here we'll write a simple statement
and now let's see if the program runs
now we'll select the class on the basis
of which we'll be running the code and
there you go we have an output so this
is the continuation of the statement in
726 for this video we'll be using
eclipse as well as intellij as these are
one of the most common and popular ides
there are also other ides available like
netbeans doctor java blue jay and so on
now continue to this part the one on
screen so now that we're done with this
let's have a look at how we can run a
similarly simple program on intellij
which is another ide now we'll need to
install it as well so let's go to google
and search for intellij let's go here
click on download and here you have two
options which is the ultimate and the
community now the community version is
free but has limitations as you can see
here there are certain limitations for
the open source version however we're
going to take this free version and
download it now i've already downloaded
it so we'll cancel this and i'm going to
run this one we'll go to next select
this location you can change it if you
want by going to browse here go next if
you want you can select any of these
options i'm going to select these
associations because this basically
means intellij also supports these
particular extensions you select the
desktop shortcut go to next and install
now we will be running intellij will not
send user statistics there you go the
ide is now open now we'll click on
create new project we select java now
from here you can also select two of
your additional frameworks if you want
here you should also make sure that this
option is selected we have java sc 1.8
now if this isn't selected you can drop
down and select this option here you can
press next now you need to make sure
this box is checked and now we're going
to create a command line application and
we are going to create a command line
application let's press next you need to
select a project name project one and
finish so now we're going to create a
very simple program how you can add two
numbers so let's get started so now
we're going to initialize the first
variable assign it with the value of 10
then for the second one assign it with
the value of 20. now we're going to
write the code to add the two numbers
some equal to first
plus second now that we're done with
that let's print the output
and there we go we're done now let's run
this code and there we go program is
running successfully so this is how you
code java in eclipse and intellij and
with that we've come to the end of this
video i hope you guys found this
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here